hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it competitive or in the case of today
it's making the creators of the art
itself engage in career combat that's
because we have a trio of talented
tinseltown talky technicians on hand
it's james gunn taking on edgar wright
versus taika waititi in a winner take
all event and although the winner won't
actually be taking anything physically
home because in all likelihood they're
not going to show up in the studio today
any of them get back to us can i get
back to you on that that's a swing and a
miss it should still be a wholly
entertaining matchup that will span the
entirety of these folks careers and
feature every galaxy planet and pub in
the known universe i don't think i can
do this was
of course you can in one corner it's
james gunn he of guardians of the galaxy
fame who's also made films about
everything from slithery creatures to
foul-mouthed anti-heroes we're gonna
need to have a real discussion about
your language in the next corner is
edgar wright he of the cornetto trilogy
acclaim who's also made films about
everything from driving babies to evil
ex-boyfriends did you make some of those
up and i'm now being told in my ear that
baby driver's actually adults driving
the car and i'll research that fact
later in the final corner it's taika
waititi your surface helmer of thor
lovin thunder who's also showcased
everything from fourth wall breaking
vampires that's us to the natural
environment of the wilder people three
heralded helmers but only one will
emerge victorious in this pit of destiny
that makes thor ragnarok look like a
sandbox in a fast food playland
well you're right here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score round three characters round four
iconic moments and then we'll do a wild
card round that could involve anything
from how many talking animals do you
have
and to how many zombies have your
characters battled to how many times
have you killed off michael rooker we
love michael rooker what'd he ever do to
you okay he was a little uptight in mall
rats and he took some time to become
likable in days of thunder but other
than that stand up a class jet house
about a big hug for your old palmer oh
right walking dead yeah and then maybe
like 10 or 12 or 30 other roles besides
those we'd love to hang out with michael
rooker you are always welcome in this
studio for it is a safe space i'm
suddenly not feeling too well today
however we have three of the most
influential filmmakers of this
millennium duking it out for a win on
versus i'm your host jury judge and judy
mark ellis you think you're so cool
don't you and as i'm fond of saying
let's get it on
prepare to die obviously look i've had
it today can we not do this right now
round one box office
ah movie theaters we love showing up in
droves to the local multiplex the dollar
theater the drive-in all with one
singular intention to cram as much
popcorn into our gullet as we can while
still following the dazzling action
electrifying intensity and laughing at
every hysterical moment sorry to
whoever's neck i coughed popcorn on but
that's simon pegg and nick frost they're
just so funny together what's that
supposed to mean one might surmise that
james gunn and or taika waititi would
have the edge in this round not because
we like them the most but they're each
helming their own franchises within the
vast expanse known as the marvel
cinematic universe or as i call it the
mc universe oh what but let's not throw
a pity party for edgar wright just yet
after all he was the original director
of ant-man and there's a reason for that
the guy's made some pretty popular
movies before and since he parted ways
with those avenger types in fact twas
edgar who directed the highest grossing
non-superhero movie of anyone in
competition today baby driver which does
have a heroic soundtrack crushed at the
bo to the tune of 227 million dollars
worldwide wow he also made nice chunks
of change with flicks like scott pilgrim
vs the world hot fuzz and the world's
end all of which hauled in at least 40
million dollars each well aren't you
pleased as punch and the film that put
him on the map sean of the dead gross 29
million dollars on a miniscule budget
all told edgar wright movies have earned
a combined 457 million dollars across
the earth making for an applaudable 76
million bucks per outing those numbers
are worth much more than just a golf
clap but his foes today did say yes to
marvel and that could give them a
sizable advantage like thor's bicep size
upper hand taiko itidi is up next and
while we're still tallying the dizzying
heights of his latest mcu entry thor
love and thunder it's expected to keep
pace with thor ragnarok which did a
mind-blowing 850 million dollars just
here on earth that's not counting all
the asgardian coin it raked in jojo
rabbit was also a hit for taika as it
took in 86 million bones
obviously and i'll give a shout out to
boy and hunt for the wilder people
because although they only team up for
just over 30 million dollars they're
what proved that ytd could tell a story
in any galaxy and like edgar wright his
earlier films had a total budget of like
i don't know four bucks and a couple sd
cards those numbers aren't exact but
here's some that are taika has a pretty
solid average thanks to the god of
thunder he's averaging 196 million
dollars per movie for a grand total that
is currently just south of a billion
bucks but one that could inflate to over
two billion dollars once my accountant
sees thor loving thunder and what it has
to offer yay us hat pat on the back
pat on the back
so now we turn our lonely eyes to james
gunn who's been making movies since
1996's tromeo and juliet if you missed
that one in the box office don't worry
do you remember 2006 yeah that year saw
slither creep its way to a respectable
12 million dollars then movie 43 did 30
mil what he was part of oh no
that movie 43
all right let's not focus on what's
dangling from wolverine's chin and
instead focus on guardians of the galaxy
the two volumes have teamed up to
generate over 1.5 billion dollars in box
office receipts and the suicide squad
not to be confused with the
oscar-winning suicide squad grabbed
another 167 million dollars worldwide
and even though james gunn has guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 on the way right now
he won't even need it to feel comfy here
in round one his home video library made
over 1.8 billion dollars when it was
released in theaters and that makes for
a per movie average of
370 million it was a good round for
edgar and a great round for tyka but
james gunn comes out on top in the box
office round and takes the early lead
one to nothing to nothing that's the
first thing you said that wasn't bad
crazy
round two tomato meter slash audience
score the good news for james gunn is
that he's got momentum heading into this
round and that was partially helped by
the 30 million dollars earned by movie
43
but the bad news is that movie 43 also
counts in the tomato meter round where i
don't think critics are going to take
all that kindly to it but let's be fair
james gunn didn't direct the whole thing
there were tons of talented folks that
contributed behind the camera to that
weird awful sketch show of a movie so
let's also toss bob odenkirk elizabeth
banks peter fairley and like i don't
know 39 other folks into that fray so
we're not gonna penalize jimmy for it
too hard but it is at four percent on
the tomato meter the good news is that
nothing else he's directed has come
close to that level of stinkiness he
actually only has one other rotten film
on the old ography and that's 49
courtesy of super which i liked from
there it's all fresh town as guardians
of the galaxy the suicide squad and its
streaming offshoot peacemaker are all at
least 90 percent fresh adding to the
potpourri is slithers 87
and guardians volume two's eighty-five
percent we just can't get enough of that
adorable tree and it's buddy the
wisecracking raccoon don't call me a
raccoon or the sweet rabbit if you
believe thor in avengers infinity war
that's as smooth a transition as i'm
gonna make to taika white td who's so
prolific in television i can kick off
with those digits what we do in the
shadows is 97 as a tv program and 96 as
a film screw this i'm flying who's with
me but he doesn't have the address so
you know i don't have the address ooh
and have you all seen reservation dogs
it's great why td created it that's at
98 and he also directed episodes of
flight of the concords which is sitting
at 94 percent for its entire run all
right now let's get to the big screen
and one of the biggest heroes of them
all so hang on hang on
back around shortly thor ragnarok is at
93 and hunt for the wilder people is it
97
this guy's on fire
boy is it 88 and eagle versus shark is
at 56 on the tomato meter but rebounds
into fresh territory with a 67 audience
score it's getting competitive here in
round two and now it's edgar wright's
turn to show off yeah
baby driver wasn't just a box office
sensation it also scored big with the
critics notching 92 percent which ties
it with shaun of the dead the fuzz is
hot on the trail as it earns 91 percent
on the tomato meter and the world's end
is 89
which is well beyond the legal limit
with the sparks brothers landing at 96
and last night in soho notching 76
it seems like it'll be pretty close on
the old math between all three of these
talents lo and behold each director is
fresh across the board with both their
tomato meter and audience score averages
james gunn is at 68
and 66 percent respectively but since he
just pinched hit for movie 43 i'm gonna
boost that up to 80 percent each whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
i put you in charge huh what i'm the
host i have absolute power
until the editors take over in which
they'll probably cut out when i rip my
shirt off revealing thor like abs in
round four oh my god
oh my god i'm good at my job
it's thorn end game abs but still i'm
still thor you look like melted ice
cream
edgar wright is also in the 80s setting
the high bar for the tomato meter with
an impossible 88 percent average per
project takeaway td is close behind as
he has an 85 average that's his exact
same total for the audience score
bolstered by jojo rabbit at 94 percent
and our flag means death at 95 percent
it's right who is nipping on tyka's
heels by this measurement as his
audience score average is 83 percent
thanks to hits like sean of the zombies
at 93 percent and spaced edgar's 1999 tv
show at 97 percent
so it appears it's going to come down to
tyka and edgar edgar and tyka both are
worthy champions in this round but i'm
gonna have to side with the high bar
setter for the almighty tomato meter
edgar wright for the w
now i didn't say the tomato meter is
infallible however it can be wrong
luckily there's a podcast about it
hosted by
i'll let you guest is there anywhere you
don't work edgar wright sneaks out of
round two with the win and it's one to
one to zero okay do we downer can we
think of something more positive round
three characters
usually one would easily grasp the
notion that this round is all about the
characters that feature in the movies
made by the filmmakers currently
battling it out on the show
metaphor
sort sorta but on this particular day i
kind of feel the need to remind everyone
of this fact simply because the
directors themselves are all such great
personalities is there a better three
amigos of fun engaging shot callers than
these three ballers james gunn edgar
wright and tyco white td have obviously
found their calling but when they're
interviewed about their projects one
could easily see them performing roles
on their own in front of the camera on
the lighted stage or just hanging out at
the neighborhood watering hole tyka is
actually a character in a few of his
films and he's made quite the mark from
vago the vamp and what we do in the
shadows to korg the friendly rock guy
from the thor flicks we love to laugh at
him and cheer him on meanwhile james
gunn films are often a family affair as
his talented actor sibling sean gunn
frequently appears in his projects and
is always memorable as a scene stealer
but we'll officially kick off this round
with edgar wright who found his muses in
a pair of lovable chums named simon and
nick yeah that's what i'm talking about
peg and frost to be exact the duo is
phenomenal in sean of the dead and from
there we yearn to see them team up again
and again luckily we got our wish as
they completed edgar's famed loose
cornetto trilogy with hot fuzz and the
world's end edgar wright was also able
to utilize one iconic character scott
pilgrim to open up a gateway for a
seemingly endless amount of fun pop-ins
can i have you can i have your autograph
mostly from embattled ex-boyfriends exes
why do you keep saying
similarly baby driver is anything but a
one-driver show the chemistry between
baby and deborah is fantabulous but also
rocking brightened are the appearances
from vets like jamie foxx's bass no need
for intros duck everybody from the
jungle to the trap no best jon hamm as
buddy and the new star on the block
darling played by isaac gonzalez and yes
also give credit to both mike myers and
michael myers for being in baby driver
simply because the joke is that good it
should be the halloween man this is a
halloween mask no the killer dude from
halloween oh you need jason no
for james gunn the characters he's most
known for weren't created out of thin
air by him but now as we look forward to
many more guardians of the galaxy
adventures can you imagine anyone else
breathing life into these creations
chris pratt as star ward zoe saldana as
gamora have had had yeah past tense such
amazing chemistry and rocket raccoon
with really anyone or anything next to
him is a laugh riot it's almost unfair
that bradley cooper is that hot of an
actor that talented of a director and
then also gets to play around in the
voiceover booth to voice the
wisecracking great outdoors brethren no
no that's the button that would kill
everyone vin diesel has a much easier
time in said vocals department
[Music]
yet his role as groot or baby groot or
teenage group is always a highlight
drax proves that big fellas can have
impeccable comedic time hey
there's no need to get personal and when
the gang gets together it's some of the
most fun you'll have in the mcu or any
other universe we're all gonna die
but gunn has also jumped into the dc
sandbox which i guess will make him the
all-time pitcher when the two comic book
juggernauts play their annual softball
game peacemaker led the way in the
suicide squad to such violently hectic
delight that the spin-off show might
have been an even bigger streaming hit
than the movie and gunn has made it
clear that we can have memorable
characters like pete davidson's black
guard that don't necessarily need a lot
of screen time to make an impression but
if eagley ever gets off we might have to
jumpstart a change.org petition why is
your pet's name so unoriginal why are
you my least favorite kid in this class
bill grant starla jack and folk continue
to make slither a sneakily rewatchable
classic and supers frank and libby make
for a tremendous amount of unhinged
chaos but when we look at smaller
properties that help the filmmakers show
what they could do takeaway td might
have set the high bar what we do in the
shadows in both the film and tv versions
take such a genius conceit and lets the
laughs echo throughout the entire castle
vlad biago deacon stu and company
establish a template that can welcome
fresh new blood and stories for
centuries to come and if we need any
more reminders of how great the tv show
is i just got one name for you detona
jackie denton he might not be a master
of disguise but he at least knows what
up dog is if you don't just ask up dog
if i didn't know what up dog was i would
at least ask ask me
from undead hoots to wilder people
hollers we arrive at thor ragnarok a
film that soared in large part thanks to
the sense of humor provided by the
genius of watidi like gun and guardians
thor valkyrie hulk and the rest of the
mcu gang weren't necessarily the brain
child of tyka but he did what no one
else on asgard could have accomplished
with those chess pieces on the board
ragnarok is the norse term for
apocalypse and he still made it fall
down funny
[Applause]
i'm just a huge fan of the sport and as
he gets to welcome in the guardians to
his directing style if this round was
already too close to call jojo rabbit
might be the tiebreaker you try taking
the most reviled dictator of the 20th
century
ever and make them a lighthearted
imaginary friend to a young boy trying
to cope with world war ii very few would
have dreamt that up at all and fewer
would have been able to pull it off
tycho was the one and that's just in
addition to all the other lasting
impressions his characters have had on
us it might have been the closest round
yet but why td takes the point and now
we're in a three-way
tie for the lead get your mind out of
the gutter thank you for this you have
really made my day
round four iconic moments so last round
we talked about sandboxes and the
characters that have these large areas
of anakin repellent with which to play
in but how much fun do we really get to
have i mean tons that's why these three
directors are here and that's why you
sat down to watch this vid i imagine
you're seated are you standing what are
you doing standing watching this send me
a pic of you standing watching this show
and explain yourself starting with round
three champion taika waititi his
wwdits moments alone would make him a
force to be reckoned with deacon's
dancing is certainly a highlight but
what gets me most is the spin-off show
that the cops have wellington paranormal
it's just so good it makes you want to
howl like a swear wolf sorry they they
werewolves
and even though i'm technically reading
what i wrote from a teleprompter right
now i'd still vouch for the reading is
stupid scene from hunt for the wilder
people only people who can't read say
things like that that flick can be
hilarious and moving within the same
sequence you hungry
that's a silly question isn't it look at
you
edgar wright knows how to make his
underdogs lovable and while i love the
type of heightened gore and destruction
we get to witness in sean of the dead
the comedic timing in certain scenes is
what separates that movie from the pack
the dogs can't look upline is so stupid
brilliant ridiculous that it surprises
me how hard i'm laughing every time but
then there's also super heart-wrenching
sequences like when you got to take down
your own mom ugh that bar brawl is a
nice precursor to the town fight in hot
fuzz and then we get treated to an
awesome bathroom battle something that
our expert researcher mark hofmeyer
adores in the world's end and it's also
in this film that we get some real
emotional bandwidth out of simon pegg's
character gary the fight between gary
and andy reveals a lot of hard truth and
makes for a standout moment in a trilogy
filled with them but no one makes a
violent take last quite like james gunn
and usually it's at the expense of
michael rooker slither is one long
creepy gross scare fest and so of course
we start there with rooker meeting his
demise by blowing the f up then in super
his head gets slammed in the gun written
bellco experiment the rook has his
noggin smashed and in the suicide squad
we go back to our roots of blowing
michael's head into oblivion at least in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the guy
gets to relax and just breathe his last
breath in relative peace guardians vol 2
may have leaned a little too much on the
laughs but there was some real emotion
behind it its predecessor flick marked
the perfect blend of mcu action and wit
with james gunn adding in his own flair
drax rocket and groot are all scene
steelers anytime they're on screen but
i'd also give major points to the
gut-wrenching outpouring between gamora
and nebula in volume 2. while folks
still hold out hope for a baby driver
vol 2 we still have all that breakneck
action of the first to keep us company
the heist scenes are shot in such
brilliant kinetic fashion that it lends
more gravity to the romantic moments
that we willingly hit the brakes for
scott pilgrim vs the world is another
right classic that hits the opening
sequence out of the stadium and sets us
up on an adventure that we didn't know
we wanted to take if your life had a
face i would punch it yeah
wait what and the combo of live action
and occasional video game aesthetic make
the film as unique as it is beloved you
are incorrigible
i don't know the meaning of the word
but pound for pound i don't know that
there's been a better combo of action
comedy and unlikely alliances than what
taika waititi gave us with thor ragnarok
is there a scene in that movie that
isn't memorable thor narrating us into
how he got into a very tricky
predicament threw his blast into full on
willy wonka madness as we meet the grand
master and then one of the all-time best
lines in a movie or trailer of the last
decade he's a friend from work plus
anytime we get to spend with korg is
memorable in my book but once again i
might lean on jojo rabbit to be the
difference it's so damn tender and
moving in a film that very easily could
have missed the entire target and been a
blemish on a resume but in the capable
loving hands of waititi it's pure
brilliance and the emotion conjured out
of a sequence like when the kid just
needs a cuddle from his mom that would
even melt the heart and heart of mark
ellis see i have feelings and my feeling
on this round is that taika waititi who
is scoreless after two rounds is now
scorching hot with another w here and he
takes the outright lead two to one to
one
what
and now it's time for the wild card
round rock and roll fantasy it's a
classic bad company tune but you need
not be in the genre of rock to pitch in
with this deciding round all three
filmmakers rely on a diverse array of
musical accompaniment to put a bow on
one scene drive another sequence and
flat out make or break an entire
storyline music is that important to our
talented triumphant that it will be the
deciding factor in which director takes
home versus gold to display on their
mantle right smack dab in the middle
if they ask i will engrave them a trophy
that may or may not be my old rec league
basketball championship that i will
hastily repurpose don't worry i got four
of those babies i too am extraordinarily
humble it's an even playing field
because none of our trio have used the
van halen tune in their films to my
knowledge crime though that may be i
still like virtually every one of these
movies take guardians of the galaxy and
now imagine it without that soundtrack
you can't fight this feeling and you
shouldn't that's more than just a
soundtrack it's a vibe that lasts
consistently throughout the first two
volumes and the download numbers
indicate that the fans can't wait for
more jay and the americans make for a
unique but indelible choice as a
sprawling violent spree is happening in
volume 2 and that should have prepared
us for what the show peacemaker would
provide while come a little bit closer
was a more mellow vibe do you want to
taste it makes for an opening dance
sequence that is absolutely positively
unskippable every time you watch
peacemaker the rest of the show features
a bunch of hair metal mainstays led by
ynt and faster pussycat plus i looked
for it there is briefly very very
quickly a van halen record on display
although that band isn't hair metal and
we can talk about that at a bar anytime
you want speaking of bars or pubs the
world's end has a host of killer tunes
as well and i love how fondly the group
of friends look back on their time as
die hard fans of the soup dragons other
divine things in the lineage of edgar
wright fair would be pre-captain marvel
brie larson in scott pilgrim vs the
world with black sheep and i'll also
give points to wade in the water from
last night in soho but if it's an edgar
wright joint you're probably saving some
room for queen don't stop me now is the
perfect jukebox companion to the zombie
carnage in shaun of the dead and
brighton rock is the tune that lets jon
hamm's veteran criminal appreciate baby
driver just a little more music is the
gasoline that fuels baby and from the
opening moments of us hearing bell
bottoms we know we're in for a ride
that's going to be as loud as it is
thrilling which leads us once again to
taika could he take three rounds in a
row well if led zeppelin has anything to
say about it quite possibly the
shredding guitar of paige and the
howling vocals of plant with immigrant
song make for the perfect norse
mythology approved entrance music for
the god of thunder in thor ragnarok we
also get treated to bowie and jojo
rabbit and if you've never seen boy stay
for the end credits courtesy of poi e
you will not be disappointed
and as great as the music and why td
films is and as perfectly casted as the
tunes are in james gunn works for me
it's edgar wright whose characters most
speak the language of music baby driver
obviously leading the charge but whether
you're policing a small town battling
zombies or simply enjoying a pub crawl
you don't just want the music there you
need it to speak for you especially if
beings from another world get mixed up
in your little bar walking evening edgar
wright gets the final point and now he's
tied with taika waititi at two apiece
how dare you which means now i have to
make a ruling between the two on my own
to crown a winner today but i could
probably also just break that tie and
give a trophy to james gunn they're also
stupendously great regardless of the
budgetary constraints their projects may
have had and as impressive as it was for
wright to make a non-franchise film into
a massive hit like baby driver i give
the slightest of edges to taika waititi
for being able to play in the universe
of marvel please all of those many
throngs of fans and also stayed true to
his independent core and off-beat sense
of humor taika is my winner today and
his trophy is on its way to corg's
office
[Music]
of course all three filmmakers are
winners in my book and i can't wait to
see what's next from each of them and
this is all just my two cents it's
pointless arguing with him now it's your
turn possibly weird viewer who's
standing up watching this vid give me
your take and let me know who your
winner would be on the world wide web
i'm on social media at mark ellis live
and stay tuned to rotten tomatoes for
all the latest in the realm of movies tv
and more thanks for watching versus i'm
mark ellis and you can call me your
friend from work
but i won't turn green just a little
salmon in the cheeks occasionally
you